In just a few minutes, you're going to
have all the tools you need to become a
networking pro. Networking is one of the
best ways to get everything you want in
life without even trying. The new job
you got because of someone you met a
year ago, the $100,000 investment
because somebody knew somebody. Even
getting a husband, it really is the
secret formula. But for many, the fear
of meeting someone new, sparking new
conversations, and being in new
environments is just holding them back.
I took the course Super Connector: The
Secret of Professional Networking on
LinkedIn Learning and decided to save
you the hour and share everything you
need to know in six concrete steps. Step
number one, write down what you want out
of life. This will make it so much
easier to know who you should be
targeting, where, and how. Along with
that, write down what do you enjoy doing
for fun, and what are your special
talents, whether people know about them
or not. Find and unique ways to display
what you want out of life throughout
your environment. I love having my phone
and laptop backgrounds be a collage of
what I want or even create a fun bingo
card with all my different goals for the
year, the month, the quarter, etc. Or
you can go the old school route and just
write it down or post it and put it all
over your environment. Step number two,
pick the setting. Charitable events make
it really easy to connect with people on
a deep emotional level. You're around
people with like passions, with very
likely emotional stories about why
they're here. Business settings are
great for professional growth. Social
events are great for making those
connections without as much pressure.
You can do it in a much more relaxed
environment. And then online settings,
whether it be LinkedIn, groups, etc.,
are great for reaching a large amount of
people pretty quickly. Different
settings are best for different types of
connections. So be intentional about
them. But here's a pro tip. Go to areas
where your skill set is scarce. So for
example, if you are a marketing
professional, go to a toy summit rather
than a marketing convention. Because at
the toy summit, if you're a marketer, oh
my goodness, you are now the hero of
that convention, of that summit, and
people are going to be after you rather
than at the marketing convention, and
you are a dumb dozen. You have now
placed yourself in a setting where you
are in demand. So, we've written our
goals, picked our setting. Now, it's
time to interact. This is probably the
step where you're getting hung up the
most figuring out what to say, who to
say it to. You're shy. Like, it can be
difficult to put yourself out there. But
what if I told you you actually didn't
need to say anything at all? That's
correct. Because what you're going to do
is instead of focusing on being the most
interesting person in the room, you're
going to be the most interested. Were
you silent or were you silenced?
This means listening intently with eye
contact, showing that you are truly
grasping what the person is saying. And
then when they're done with their
statements, go deeper with them by
asking really thoughtful questions.
Questions like how come and how did that
change your perception of X. If someone
mentions a new job they got, ask them,
"Is it everything they thought it would
be?" Making people feel special makes
you memorable. The second way you want
to interact with others is by not asking
what they can do for you, but what you
can do for them. Ask not what your
country can do for you. Ask what you can
do for your country.
Being helped makes others so much more
eager to help you. So when you're
connecting with someone about their new
job, venture, etc., ask them, "How can I
help you with this?" Make sure that they
know you're expecting an answer right
now. Because if you simply say, "Oh,
reach out if you need any help," they
likely won't. The third biggest tip for
this interacting phase that we're in is
before asking for advice, say, "You seem
to be an expert." Then go into the
question you have. You seem to be an
expert. How would you go about this roll
out? People love hearing phrases like
that. They love feeling seen. They love
feeling admired. So tap into that to
further your connection with them, even
when you're asking them for help. Step
number four, manage your relationships.
After you get someone's card,
immediately text them, "Hi, Greg, this
is Nia. It was so great to meet you
about X, Y, and Z at blank today." Also,
have your contact photo added to your
phone. That way, when you text them,
they have the opportunity to also see a
visual of who they're talking to
because, you know, maybe you weren't
that memorable. I don't know. I don't
know. But but just in case, we want to
make it easy for them to remember. Oh
yes, that red hair. I know who just
texted me. Now, this tip is specific for
iPhone users. Android, I hope you all
have a setting where it's easy to share
your contact photo with a new contact.
If you don't, a great option is to also
after sending that initial text, take a
little selfie. just
click and send it over within the
message. I know it's going to feel
weird. However, it will likely be very
very appreciated because again, it's
we're trying to remember each other. At
the end of the day, take a quick audit
of who you connected with and track it
in some sort of spreadsheet because what
gets measured gets mastered. and you
being able to see in one clear view
everyone you've connected with and all
the numbers you've gotten and people you
need to follow up with, it'll make it so
much easier to actually master
networking. I've created a free
spreadsheet you can steal right now
using the link in the description. Step
number five, follow up. We need to make
sure we're managing the connections
we're making while also remaining top of
mind for them. So the day after you make
this connection, text, email, whatever
this person and say, "Hey, I would love
to have a coffee chat, virtual coffee, a
walk-in talk with you. I am free at
these times next week. Let me know what
works best for your schedule." Be
accommodating while also making it easy
for that person to quickly follow up and
say yes. And if they say no, add that to
the spreadsheet because again, what gets
measured gets mastered. Doesn't mean
give up on that connection. just follow
up again a week later and see if you can
make something happen. And then step
number six, invest in your speaking
skills. Investing doesn't always mean
money. It can also mean time. For
example, speaking to a camera for just
60 seconds every single day about
anything you want while making sure
you're maintaining eye contact with the
lens will do wonders for your speaking
abilities. When I say camera, I'm not
saying no Canon Pro, whatever. Just take
out your phone camera and talk directly
to it. If you want to take it a step
further, there are classes, seminars,
webinars, etc. that you can take as
well, both in person and online. But
there we go, the six steps you need to
know to master networking and allow it
to actually transform your life rather
than just sitting in the corner and
wondering why the hell your life isn't
turning out the way you want it to. And
I highly encourage you to set up some
sort of event for you to attend either
online or in person once a week for the
rest of the year. You've taken a very
big step by watching this video in the
first place. So now let's actually take
it out into the real world and let it
actually change our lives. So make sure
you give this video a like and a
comment. Thank you so much for watching
and I'll talk to you all later. Bye.